I WANT TO GO TO THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN LLOYD DOGGETT, A
MEMBER OF THE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE WHICH HAS BEEN TRYING
TO GET TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS SINCE
2019.
CONGRESSMAN, HERE YOU ARE,
VICTORY FROM A SUPREME COURT
WITH TRUMP'S JUDGES ON IT COMING
SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT, HAND
THOSE TAX RETURNS OVER TO YOUR
COMMITTEE.
LET'S START WITH THE MOST BASIC
QUESTION.
WHEN DO YOU EXPECT TO GET THE
DOCUMENTS?
>> I'M HOPING WE WILL GET THEM
BY NEXT WEEK.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT VICTORY FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND IT'S TRUE
THAT THE EFFORTS HAVE GONE ON
FOR THREE YEARS ON THE LAWSUIT.
I ACTUALLY MADE THE FIRST MOTION
TO GET THESE TAX RETURNS ON
FEBRUARY 3, 2017.
SO WE'RE COMING UP ON ALMOST
FIVE YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THIS.
AND REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE
AIDED AND ABETTED HIM IN EVERY
WAY.
THE STATUTE'S EXPLICIT.
IT SAYS "SHALL TURN THESE OVER
TO THE WAYS AND MEANS COMMITTEE.
WE HE HAD PLENTY OF REPUBLICANS
WHO WOULD BLOCK AND OBSTRUCT AND
REFUSE TO TAKE ACTION.
AND THEN A TRUMP-APPOINTED JUDGE
SAT ON THE LAWSUIT FOR 2 1/2
YEARS.
AND SO NOW WE ARE RIGHT UP
AGAINST THE FINAL DEADLINE.
WE KNOW THE SAME HOUSE
REPUBLICANS THAT BLOCKED ACCESS
TO HIS RETURNS WHEN WE COULD
HAVE GOTTEN THEM A LONG, LONG
TIME AGO HAVE ALREADY BEGUN
PUTTING OUT STATEMENTS THAT MAKE
IT CLEAR IF WE DON'T GET ACTION
BEFORE THE JANUARY 3rd DEADLINE,
WE WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO HOLD
HIM TO ANY LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FULFILL OUR
LEGISLATIVE RESPONSIBILITIES TO
SEE WHETHER THE IRS IS
CONDUCTING ITS AUDIT TO THESE
APPROPRIATELY.
>> SO, LET'S BE CLEAR HERE.
ON JANUARY 3rd, THEY GET CONTROL
OF YOUR COMMITTEE IN THE HOUSE
AND THEY END IT, THAT'S CLEAR.
SO, YOU'VE GOT JUST ABOUT SIX
WEEKS.
YOU'RE SAYING NOW YOU DON'T
EXPECT TO GET THEM UNTIL AFTER
THANKSGIVING.
THEN YOU'VE GOT MEMBERS ON
HOLIDAY AND THE HOLIDAYS,
CHRISTMAS, NEW YEARS.
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO HERE,
CONGRESSMAN?
OR IS THIS SORT OF A VICTORY
WHERE YOU WIN BUT YOU CAN'T
ACTUALLY EXECUTE?
>> TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE READY TO
WORK HOLIDAYS, WEEKEND, WHATEVER
IT TAKES TO GET THIS JOB DONE.
THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE HERE.
AND WE CANNOT DEFAULT AT THE
LAST MINUTE.
I KNOW WE WILL BE ACTING ON
ADVICE OF COUNSEL, THE SAME
COUNSEL THAT WON THIS DECISION
TODAY AND HAS WON IN FACT NO
JUDGE HAS EVER RULED FOR TRUMP'S
SIDE ON THIS ISSUE.
SO IT'S CLEAR THE LAW IS CLEAR
OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS CLEAR, AND
REPUBLICAN OBSTRUCTION AND
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO
OBSTRUCT IS CLEAR.
SO WE NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY.
AND I HOPE WE BEGIN THAT REVIEW
NEXT WEEK.
JUST TO BE CLEAR ABOUT IT, THIS
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE RECORDS
IMMEDIATELY BECOME PUBLIC.
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO PRIVACY
PROTECTION.
IN FACT, IT'S A FELONY TO LEAK
OR DISCLOSE THESE RETURNS UNTIL
OUR COMMITTEE ACTS.
>> SO IF YOUR COMMITTEE IS
UNABLE TO DO WHAT IT NEEDS TO
DO, BECAUSE THAT'S OBVIOUSLY AN
AMORPHEUS TERM.
BUT ARE YOU AREN'T ABLE TO GET
EVERYTHING DONE BY JANUARY 3rd,
AND EACH ONE OF HIS RETURNS IS
GOING TO BE THIS THICK, I'M
HOLDING MY HANDS UP THE SIZE OF
THE TV.
SO THEN, AND THE PUBLIC ISN'T
GOING TO GET TO SEE THEM BECAUSE
OF SECRECY, THE GOP TAKES OVER,
WHAT HAPPENS?
NO ONE EVER SEES THEM, NOTHING
HAPPENS, THEY'RE GONE?
>> THERE CERTAINLY IS THE
ALTERNATIVE OF MAKING THESE
DOCUMENTS PUBLIC, AND THE TIME
PRESSURE HERE CREATES AN ADDED
REASON TO CONSIDER DOING THAT.
I'M NOT READY WITHOUT HAVING
REVIEWED ANY OF IT TO SAY THAT
WE NEED TO ACT IMMEDIATELY ON
MAKING THEM PUBLIC.
BUT THERE IS A WAY THAT WE CAN
FORWARD THOSE TAX RETURNS TO THE
HOUSE AND THE HOUSE CAN ACT ON
THIS.
AND IT WOULD HAVE THE EFFECT OF
MAKING IT PUBLIC, AND THEN THEY
COULD BE REVIEWED WITH MORE
CARE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE GOT TO CONSIDER
IF THEY CONTINUE TO OBSTRUCT
HERE.
>> WELL, IT IS CRUCIAL TO KNOW
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE THAT OPTION.
AND, AGAIN, EVEN THOUGH THAT MAY
BE AGAINST HIS WISHES, IT WOULD
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE PAST 45
YEARS OF PRECEDENT WITH
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
RELEASING THOSE RETURNS.
CONGRESSMAN, I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I WANT TO GO STRAIGHT TO RYAN
GOODMAN NOW, FORMER SPECIAL
COUNSEL AT THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT.
SO LET'S JUST START THERE WHERE
CONGRESSMAN DOGGETT FINISHED.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE, HE MADE
THAT CLEAR.
NIGHTS, WEEKENDS, THEY'RE GOING
TO WORK THEM.
IF THEY CAN'T GET IT DONE, THEY
HAVE THIS OPTION.
DO YOU THINK THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
DO -- AND I KEEP SAYING
EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO DO
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
IS, BUT TO LITERALLY READ
THROUGH EACH OF THIS -- THIS
THICK -- OR MORE BEFORE THE GOP
TAKES OVER.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO DO EVERYTHING THEY WANT TO
DO.
SO WILL THEY RELEASE ANY OF IT
PUBLICLY?
AND THAT IS THE QUESTION THAT
WAS KIND OF BURNING BEHIND THE
SCENES OF THE DIFFERENT JUDGES
THAT ENTERTAINED THIS QUESTION.
SO THE DISTRICT COURT JUDGE AT
THE VERY END OF HIS OPINION
SAYS, THIS MAY BE NOT RIGHT OR
WISE, BUT IT IS THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE WAYS AND MEANS
COMMITTEE'S RIGHT TO DECIDE WHAT
TO DO IN TERMS OF RELEASING IT.
AND THE COURT OF APPEALS SAID
SOMETHING SIMILAR.
>> NOW THE APPEALS COURT RULING
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
YOU LISTENED IN ON THE ENTIRE
HEARING TODAY, WHICH YOU WERE
ABLE TO DO.
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO PLAY SOUND
BITES FROM IT.
BUT WE ARE ABLE TO QUOTE FROM
IT.
A JUDGE APPOINTED BY TRUMP CUT
TRUMP'S LAWYER OFF WHEN THE
LAWYER CALLED THE AUGUST SEARCH
AT MAR-A-LAGO A RAID.
RIGHT?
THE JUDGE CUTS HIM OFF AND SAYS,
DO YOU THINK A RAID IS THE RIGHT
TERM FOR THE EXECUTION OF A
WARRANT TO WHICH TRUMP'S LAWYER
APOLOGIZES FOR USING THE, QUOTE,
LOADED TERM.
ALL RIGHT, AND IT'S CLEAR WHERE
THIS PANEL OF JUDGE AS PEERS TO
BE.
IF THE COURT DECIDES IN FAVOR OF
THE DOJ, SAYS ENOUGH OF THE
SPECIAL MASTER REVIEW WHAT,
HAPPENS TO THE MAR-A-LAGO CASE
TIME LINE?
>> SO I THINK THIS MIGHT HAPPEN
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
THEY WOULD BASICALLY OVERTURN
JUDGE CANNON.
AND SHE WOULD BE NO LONGER,
ESSENTIALLY IN, CONTROL OF THE
MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS.
THEY WOULD BASICALLY BE SAYING
YOU SHOULD NEVER HAVE EXERCISED
JURISDICTION IN THE FIRST PLACE,
JUDGE CANNON, YOU DIDN'T HAVE
IT, IT WAS SO BIZARRELY UNUSUAL,
IT'S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE.
SO THEY TAKE IT AWAY FROM HER.
WHAT THE CHIEF JUDGE WAS
ACTUALLY JUST DISCUSSING, IN
PART, SHOULD WE SAY IT'S TOTALLY
VACATED?
WE'VE TOTALLY REVERSED HER.
SO THEY'RE JUST REALLY PLAYING
WITH THOSE PARTICULAR WORDS, AND
THEN ALL OF IT WILL GO TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> AND THEY CAN THEN GO, AND
YOU'VE GOT OBVIOUSLY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVOLVED AND THINGS CAN
GO VERY QUICKLY IF THEY SO
CHOOSE.
RYAN, THANKS VERY MUCH.